these are the last remaining ukrainian
fighters in the azov stall steel plant
now they are prisoners of war
they survived russia's onslaught for
more than two months in the steel plant
their future is now unknown their
surrender brings a much needed victory
for russian forces in the strategically
important port city of mariopol
the minister of defence has reported to
presidents of russia on the end of the
operation and the complete liberation of
the azov style industrial complex and of
the city of mariopol from ukrainian
fighters
the kremlin says those who've
surrendered will be treated in line with
international norms some russian
lawmakers have demanded they be tried
for war crimes and one said they should
face the death penalty
sergey shoigu announced his forces
alongside russian-backed separatists
will soon claim full control over the
lugansk region in eastern ukraine
a victory that's long overdue for his
forces
forces the defense minister wants to
expand
he revealed plans for 12 more military
units to be added to the military
districts in western russia in response
to finland and sweden applying to join
nato
that expansion needs more manpower and
the russian lawmakers may have the
solution the state duma on friday said
it's considering a bill that would allow
russians over the age of 40 and
foreigners over the age of 30 to sign up
for the military
the website of the russian parliament's
lower house the state duma said the move
would enable the military to utilize the
skills of older professionals familiar
with the use of high precision weapons
and military equipment
as what russia calls its special
military operation nears the three-month
mark there is no indication from either
side of an end to the conflict
dorsochapari al jazeera moscow